[Aplausos]
bueno siempre que me presentan tengo
como un problemita hoy no es tanto el
caso pero generalmente tienen una mesa
compartida y la situación vendría a ser
tipo les presento a la especialista en
tal cosa contra el posgrado al
secretario adjunto del gremio histórico
de no sé qué y bueno esta piba mucho
gusto y yo hago buen día
pero bueno convengamos que está bueno
que para que te den espacio para decir
cosas nos falta mucho más que tener algo
para decir
es algo que celebró este yo tengo 18
años y tengo muchas cosas por decir como
mucha gente de mi generación de más de
menos el tema es que desde donde yo
estoy hacia abajo la tenemos más
complicada para decir algunas cosas yo
cuando empecé a militar en mi centro de
estudiantes tenía 13 años
y tenía un apodo que era pendeja
atrevida pendeja por que tenía 13 14
años y atrevida básicamente porque si
tenía algo para decirlo se lo decía
sencillo pero mis compañeros solían
chocar con esa idea entonces me decían
pendeja atrevida y les molestaba un poco
generalmente mi presencia pero yo creo
que decir igual para mí hacía que no me
importe mucho lo que decían en el
sentido de que para mí decir igual es
una filosofía una decisión política y
sobre todo una forma de vida me parece
que la militancia es una forma de vida
que consiste principalmente en
cuestionarlo todo no tanto en tener
razón como en pensar que no hay tal
razón y todo cuestionarlo y en tiempos
donde la realidad parece ser un paisaje
y nos invitan a pensar en solamente
nosotros mismos y nosotras mismas
cuestionarlo todo creo que es realmente
revolucionario y yo adopté esa forma de
vida esos son mis principios
y empiezan lejos lejos yo tenía tipo 10
11 años no recuerdo tenía una novela que
veía siempre mientras tomaban las quick
y de repente un día la interrumpieron
con una cadena nacional primero sobre
tipo como porque la interrumpen pero me
quedé viendo esa cadena nacional y mi
nueva tira juvenil pasaron a ser las
cadenas nacionales y mi mamá se reserva
bueno cálmate nena 11 años teléfono
porque no sé si ahora quiero ver esto y
ahora quiero entender esto porque ahora
no porque todo es después porque siempre
es el futuro pero bueno en algún momento
deje de decir cosas y empecé a hacerlas
no sola con mis compañeros y compañeras
y en una buena más de una pero en una
tomamos la escuela con texto más o menos
habían tirado una reforma por la ventana
que quería ser que trabajemos gratis
para empresas cuestiones semejantes y un
medio de comunicación me invita a hablar
con ellos del tema y pasa lo siguiente
ofelia de la pregunta
con la toma del colegio haber contado un
poco con el cuál es la intención de
ustedes tomando el colegio
y en principio tenemos 22 vertientes de
nuestro reclamo en primer lugar estamos
yendo contra esta reforma que nos parece
anti educativa
chiquita el reclamo el reclamo está todo
bien sentido ahí explica me explica me
explica
bueno el tema acá es esa chiquita tan
molesto después de esto igual me
gritaron dictador a autoritaria que todo
eso lo hacía con la plata esos impuestos
cosas clásicas de los medios de
comunicación en la argentina porque no
me molestaron tanto como ese detalle
chiquita porque el dictado ahora todo lo
demás no sino que tiene que ver con
valoraciones que hicieron a partir de
hablar conmigo chiquita no importa yo
podía decir cualquier cosa y sin embargo
yo seguía siendo chiquita no tenía mucho
valor lo que yo decía y sin embargo me
invitaban a su programa y me hacían
hablar con ellos pero no me deslegitima
van desde el minuto uno este tipo
directamente tiene malas intenciones es
sabido provechos también con buenas
intenciones algo que me dicen seguido es
algo tipo vos sos el futuro son nuestra
esperanza además quizás si la bola de
cristal no existe puede que lo sea pero
me parece que llegó la hora de no
solamente tratarnos de futuro sino de
tratarnos representa y me parece que
nuestros esfuerzos están a la altura de
que nos otorgan ese reconocimiento
nuestra militancia está a la altura de
ser presente y no
futuro futuro quizás tal vez no lo sé
pero presente aquí ahora es algo que ya
somos y me parece que llegó la hora de
que nos den esa condición en ese sentido
me parece que muchas veces se liga lo
democrático a cosas equivocadas y se
piensa que lo único que tiene el valor
es lo etario es la edad es el ser grande
y al final de cuentas hay momentos en
los que la experiencia no es tanto
cuantitativa como cualitativa por
ejemplo un tipo horroroso de 50 años me
quiere explicar que nunca pisa una
escuela pública cómo tiene que ser mi
educación me parece que yo que la he
vivido toda mi vida y que viviría en sus
modificaciones tengo más para decir al
respecto como por ejemplo un hombre de
50 años que no tiene capacidad de gestar
quiere explicarle una mujer a una mujer
si tiene o no que abortar la mujer capaz
tiene 12 años pero es la es la que puede
atravesar un embarazo entonces tiene más
cosas para decir con un chabón de 50 ahí
la edad tampoco lo marca y con este
ejemplo voy a mi segunda maldición o
bendición depende de donde lo mires y es
que además de ser chiquita soy mujer o
sea de vuelta generalmente no sé de lo
que
puedo hablar quizás de cocina de
maternidad cocina maternidad ano de
materna tampoco en argentina el mes
pasado rechazaron el proyecto de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo de
aborto legal entonces maternidad tampoco
es nuestro asunto sólo de cocina vamos a
hablar nuevo bastante mal en esta vida
si de eso se trata y entonces de repente
nos encontramos con estos tipos
si te entiendo mira en argentina mueren
200 mujeres por electrocución al año
entonces yo basándome en tu argumento
digo bueno podemos tenemos que sacar la
electricidad de todo el país porque
muere un montón de mujeres te parecería
lógico eso me imagino que no me imagino
que no de toda francia no podemos quitar
la electricidad de todo maíz no podemos
seguir quitando niños de los vientres
maternos
la solución es educar a la gente en el
uso correcto de la electricidad como la
solución es educar a la gente en eeuu
en el uso correcto de su sexualidad
termine diciendo el señor me quiere
enseñar a vivir mi sexualidad a lo que
iba con este ejemplo es que si nosotras
estamos en silencio y estos tipos llenan
el silencio me mato directamente así que
no no nos callamos más nosotras ocupamos
ese silencio robamos ese silencio no lo
apropiamos este y todo eso a partir de
escucharnos entre nosotras
históricamente si nos ha dicho las
mujeres que la única manera que tenemos
que convivir es odiando nos porque una
es la que te roba el novio la otra es en
la que es más linda que vos ahora que es
más gordo la que es más todo cuando no
el feminismo nos viene a decir escuchen
se loco porque les están sacando un
lugar enorme y lo pueden tener si se
juntan si están juntas y así lo hicimos
y el silencio les empezó a tocar a otros
a los que nos han subestimado toda la
vida porque creo que boquiabiertos no te
no te salen las palabras no puedes
pronunciarlas muy bien entonces el
silencio se lo hemos dejado a ellos y me
parece que yo con lo que venía diciendo
siendo chiquita y siendo mujer la podría
pasar verdaderamente para el [ __ ] pero
mi receta para que no sea tan malo no se
trata de que yo sea muy valiente
sino que justamente somos muchas las
valientes no se trata de que antes cosas
como estas yo tengo mucha paciencia sino
que por contrario somos muchísimas las
impacientes y que entonces preferimos no
perder tiempo en algunas cosas este y
ahí lo más importante en donde todo
desemboca es en lo colectivo en lo
poderoso de lo colectivo de un colectivo
de encontrarse a mí me costó mucho decir
que era feminista porque sentía que me
faltaba en libros encima años lo que sea
y después me di cuenta que ser feminista
no tenía que ver con asignarse una
característica a una sino por decir y
remarcar y dejar registrado que me
siento parte de ese colectivo no tanto
de lo que puede significar ser feminista
sino decir sutil el lado de esas pibas
de este lado de la vereda de este lado
de la historia eso para mí terminó por
hacer y por hacer que yo pueda decirme a
mí misma feminista porque todo se trata
de eso de ese colectivo de hermanarse la
palabra que para mí mejor va con todo
esto es hermanas somos hermanas porque
con entre hermanas puedes tener
diferencias o sea muchas de piensa que
el feminismo como son cosas
está todo bien nunca se pelean es como
todas las manos por los derechos no
tenemos diferencias políticas no somos
estúpidas o sea son los varones pueden
discutir cosas pueden estar en
desacuerdo no estamos ante acuerdo pero
lo que tienen en particular las hermanas
es que a pesar de poder pelearse un
montonazo si se la pudren a tu hermana
de la pudren a vos a tu hermana no la
tocan y con nosotras tenemos esa misma
filosofía y hay muchos que me dicen loca
está muy enojada cálmate y está para
enojarse las cosas están para estar
enojadas normalista mi destino ja obvió
que voy a estar enojada pero igual
aparte lo más importante es que me
acusan de estar enojada yo no voy a
sonreír como el patriarcado me pide que
sonría como las publicidades en las
cuales la mina de te dice estas
estructuras lavando ese plato fregando
el plato y lo hace así frente al plato y
no puede para que llegue mister músculo
balón con músculos y dado para tiki en
un segundo te lava el plato y láminas y
como que grandes visten muscular no la
míster músculo le revoleó el plato por
la cabeza si me pasa eso es asco en esos
momentos no sonrío y no voy
sonreír como me piden que sonría pero si
tenemos momentos de sonreír nosotras si
se fijan en cómo funciona movimiento
feminista es una gran fiesta las mujeres
y las disidencias organizamos una fiesta
tremenda llena de glitter llena de
bombos llena de canciones pero el motor
de estas fiestas son heridas detrás de
todo el glitter somos profundamente
guerreras porque primero nos han
violentado muchísimas veces desde el
minuto uno nos violentan en el momento
en el que íbamos a la juguetería con
nuestros padres y de repente decíamos
quieres autito no es peligroso pero pero
no es un auto de verdad papá no es
peligroso salí de segundo holanda las
barbies clásico después nos violentaban
también cuando poníamos una tira juvenil
un programa de la tarde y veías una
relación en la cual la mina el chabón se
iba estaba con otra gente a la noche
volvía y la mina le se h papá que
hiciste hay drogas es una histérica
porque le dicen histérica eso histérica
es una persona que da vueltas en una
cosa que dice bien claro no quiero cada
es esto lo que podemos cuestionar es si
el único tipo de relación posible es una
relación en la cual es monogámico infiel
todo el tiempo
hay otras pero cuando existe el pacto la
piba no es histérico pero que nos
enseñaron a nosotras a ok él hace lo que
quiere y si yo me quejo si un stick
antes no me dejó hacer lo que quieras
también todo solamente por estar en esa
relación de los rotos pero bueno eso
también es que nos violenten violentadas
porque ir por la calle nos da miedo es
bien corta nos da miedo en la calle no
abrir la puerta de la casa es un horror
porque hablando con los auriculares y no
sabemos si tenerlos fuertes y más bajos
porque los pones al palo y decís
buenísimo porque no pienso tanto en la
[ __ ] pero de repente se si los tienes
muy altos se va a pasar a alguien a algo
lo que sea y no están lo suficientemente
atenta entonces los que estén abajo para
no pensar en eso pero si los tienes muy
fuertes no pensás en eso entonces te
puede pasar algo
eso también es violencia y violentadas
porque pasa algo pasa algo todo el
tiempo nos matan todo el tiempo se
llevan a nuestras compañeras mataron a
luego la materna melina mataron a
ángeles mataron las cifras que tienden
cada vez más al infinito nos matan
y también es violencia cuando después
los medios de comunicación hablan de eso
de una forma tan cínica y morbosa en la
cual es culpa de una porque estaba yendo
a pegar drogas o porque salía mucho a
bailar o porque como estaba vestida o
porque era mujer entonces bueno así
directo eso también es violencia y hemos
llorado muchos éramos muchísimos
lloramos cada vez que sentíamos que la
norma no la nuestra
éramos cada vez que deseábamos pero no
podíamos desear fuéramos muchas veces
mucho tiempo entonces ahora no vamos a
sonreír porque mister músculo nos limpia
el plato vamos a sonreír porque ya no
estamos solas vamos a sonreír porque ya
no parece ser nuestra culpa porque ya no
estamos locas el patriarcado no solo te
oprime el patriarcado también se encarga
de que vos pienses que todo lo que te
pasa es porque vos te lo buscaste o que
algunas cosas no son porque usted las
buscaste pero igual esta es loca por
quejarte tanto no sano el feminismo nos
vino a decir sonrían porque ahora tienen
a alguien con quien abrazarse sonrían
porque ya saben
es la culpa y estamos sonriendo en ese
momento sintiendo nuestras heridas pero
queriendo cicatrizar las derrotarlas y
en ese sentido quiero remarcar yo no
creo que exista tal cosa como la
esperanza o como la fe no creo en esas
cosas yo creo que si dios existe nos
odia entonces no voy a confiar en él me
parece que la esperanza el pensar que
las cosas van a ser mejores porque si no
me sirven no me funciona me parece que
la promesa de algo mejor nos la da la
fuerza nuestra fuerza dispuesta en una
causa esa es mi promesa de algo mejor yo
creo que con la fuerza dispuesta en esta
causa las cosas se van a transformar van
a cambiar nuestra fuerza que está en
todas partes nuestras fuerzas que están
escuelas nuestra fuerza que está en las
calles nuestra fuerza que está en
lugares de trabajo
nuestra fuerza que está en las cenas
familiares nuestra fuerza que está en
nuestra en las camas cuando cogemos
nuestra fuerza que está en todas partes
nos estamos quejando en todas partes y
que no solo nos quejamos no sólo
denunciamos sino que estamos empezando a
construir una sociedad diferente en esos
lugares con esa fuerza esa fuerza
es mi promesa de algo mejor y estoy
completamente convencida nuestra fuerza
es lo que nos dice que vamos a vencer
que el patriarcado se va a caer y no
porque lo diga yo sino porque se está
viendo justamente en todo lo que nombré
pero también porque lo digo yo la
pendeja atrevida la chiquita la minita
que no sabe lo que habla bueno una de
estas es este modelo en stock que hace
una revolución mira qué loco pero no una
revolución como las que ya conocemos no
con sus recetas de siempre es una
revolución distinta es nuestra se podría
decir incluso que es una revolución
creativa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]